Люди почали задумуватися, у якій оселі їм жити,
у якій оселі жити їхній родині.
Конопляний утеплювач зовсім не горить, економить на опаленні,
регулює вологість, у ньому дуже затишно.
Також він є дуже ефективним звукоізолятором.
Мене звати Сергій Коваленков, я є засновником компанії «Hempire»,
котра займається екологічним будівництвом з конопель.
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
[Наддніпрянщина]
[Київ]
Я зустрівся з цією технологією в Австралії,
[Сергій Коваленков]
і зрозумів, що ми можемо створити дійсно на 100% природнє в'яжуче,
котре не буде містити ніякого цементу.
Дуже важливим завданням для мене було розробити це з матеріалів на території України,
щоб бути незалежним від імпорту.
І ми це зробили.
Коли ми виготовляємо цей утеплювач на будівельному майданчику,
ми замішуємо наше в'яжуче з вапна, костриці конопель та води.
У момент твердіння ця суміш поглинає CO2.
І потім він перетворюється на камінь,
котрий ми штукатуримо за допомогою вапна або глини.
Коли ми розроблювали наш утеплювач,
ми ставили акцент на екологічності матеріалів.
У нашій формулі є тільки природні речовини: вапно, мінерали,
немає ніякого піску, немає ніякого цементу,
тобто ми сфокусувалися на розробці на 100% природнього в'яжучого.
Ось так виглядає наш утеплювач.
Він починає поглинати СО2 з повітря,
і ми пішли вгору, вгору, вгору,
це є елементами каркасу.
Для конопель немає значення яка форма будівлі:
чи це квадрат, чи купол, чи соти.
Щоб навчитися утеплювати будинок коноплями,
треба декілька годин для людини, яка ніколи не стикалася з такою технологією.
Так і будинок [площею] 100 метрів квадратних,
ми можемо утеплити за два-три тижні.
Тобто це дуже швидкий процес,
немає ніякої технологічної паузи, як із бетоном, наприклад.
Ми можемо трамбувати нашу суміш і знімати опалубку відразу після встановлення.
Ми — не єдина компанія, яка будує екологічні будинки, і це добре.
Так, є компанії, котрі будують з очерету, соломи.
Цей напрямок є дуже перспективним.
[Будинок Дмитра Терещенка]
Дмитро був одним із перших наших клієнтів.
Це був непростий об'єкт,
коли треба було над існуючою будівлею надбудувати другий поверх для великої родини.
Ви відчуваєте цю тишу, спокій?
Можеш залишитись сам на сам зі своїми думками.
Це хибна думка. Троє синів знайдуть тебе всюди.
Кондиціонери ми не використовуємо, тому що в принципі вологість ідеальна
і взимку, і влітку.
Десь 50 - 55% [вологості], сухо і легко дихати.
Стіни дихають.
Утеплювач на основі конопель поглинає вологу.
Тобто зараз я поливаю його водою.
Раз, два, три. Він, як губка накопичує вологу.
Потім без проблем він може висохнути, і нічого з ним не станеться.
Втрата [тепла] за добу — один градус.
Тобто нагрів, наприклад, до 20  [градусів],
і через п'ять днів, незважаючи на морози, буде 15 [градусів].
Але, в принципі, менше 15  [градусів] не знижується  [температура повітря].
Конопляний утеплювач здатний накопичувати тепло,
а потім його віддавати.
Коли котел працює — стіни накопичують [тепло],
коли ви вимикаєте котел,
то стіни віддають накопичене тепло назад у будинок.
Несли мішки з цим трилисником,
і тут у мене були будівельники,
вони подумали, що я займаюсь чимось незаконним.
Навіть, я так зрозумів, два будівельника набрали два пакети [конопель],
я їм сказав, що це не має сенсу, бо конопля — технічна, тому не треба.
Це справа мого життя,
я бачу, що ми можемо виготовляти висококласні енергоефективні матеріали в Україні,
нам не треба ніякого імпорту,
і ми це робимо прямо зараз.
Нам колись казали:
«Навіщо ти це робиш? Змішуй ці коноплі з цементом, все буде добре».
Але ми обрали інший шлях, більш болісний.
Зараз ми проводимо іспити нашого матеріалу в лабораторіях,
ми будемо це робити і в країнах ЄС.
Ми хочемо показати наскільки він ефективний,
у плані здоров'я, в плані енергоефективності.
[Студія йоги]
Йога-студія — це взагалі унікальний проєкт.
Ми почали утеплювати в січні, коли був дуже холодний період для Києва.
Я пам'ятаю, як зараз,
це було 2 січня, коли всі бешкетували: зустрічали Новий рік,
ми з моєю бригадою три роки тому почали утеплювати цю йога-студію.
У цьому просторі ми утеплювали все: і стіни, і підлогу, і перекриття.
Це результат утеплення бетону з середини.
Шар утеплювання монтувався безпосередньо на бетон.
Рівень вологості сягає близько 50%.
І дуже комфортно у цьому просторі проводити такі заняття, як ми з вами зараз бачимо .
Конопляний утеплювач перетворився на каміння,
і зараз дуже ефективно регулює вологу, і накопичує, і віддає тепло.
Утеплювач на основі конопель зовсім не боїться вогню.
Я можу так дуже довго стояти,
можу стояти тут 20, 30 хвилин, годину,
нічого з ним не станеться.
Вогонь зовсім не розповсюджується по утепленню,
він захищає каркас від горіння.
Ми стали першою компанією у світі, яка почала будувати купольні будинки з конопель.
Купольний проєкт є унікальним:
тут зустрілися дві технології.
Перший купол замовник побудував із пінополістиролбетону,
[Будинок Сергія Бойка]
інший купол побудований із технічних конопель.
Ми його перетягнули на сторону добра і світла:
на сторону конопель.
Один раз використали дерево,
один раз використали матеріали,
ми не будемо це перебудовувати, ремонтувати постійно,
і знову витрачати кошти, і, знову ж таки, матеріали.
Тобто одна сім'я, як то кажуть, один будинок.
Тобто, якщо можна сказати про це будівництво,
що воно є екологічним не тільки тому, що ми побудували екологічний будинок,
але який ми слід залишили за собою екологічний.
Чи вивезли ми десять тон сміття?
Тому я собі знаю, у мене ще такий гарний післясмак, я б сказав, після будівництва.
Я знаю, що тут використано мінімум матеріалів,
які несуть по собі тривалий час переробки, розпаду і т.д.
З моменту початку Майдану, у 2014 році в Україні з'явилася велика кількість стартапів.
Також у сфері енергоефективності.
Зараз наші громадяни починають розуміти, що ми можемо все самі.
Ми бачимо дуже велику кількість компаній, які сфокусовані на розробці таких рішень.
Ми бачимо незалежних молодих людей,
які не бояться, які йдуть вперед.
Вони дуже креативні, вони дуже волелюбні.
Я переконаний, що в нашої країни — дуже велике майбутнє.
[Автор проєкту: Богдан Логвиненко
Продюсерка: Каріна Пілюгіна]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Михайло Шелест, Микола Носок]
[Ukraїner спільно з
greencubator]